plötzlich hat die Polizei mal
durchgegriffen
3000 Festnahmen plötzlich eine Kampagne
gegen Kinderehen im indischen
Bundesstaat Assam Männern deren Braut
bei der Hochzeit noch keine 18 war
drohen zwei Jahre Haft war die Braut
noch keine 14 können es sieben Jahre und
mehr werden
Akbar Ali hatte eine 17-Jährige
geheiratet
2021 war das jetzt soll er dafür büßen
von der Polizeistation geht's in den
Knast zurück bleibt die Ehefrau cartoon
ein gemeinsames Kind und die große Frage
wie es jetzt weitergehen soll für die
Familie
sie ist 6 Monate alt woher soll ich
jetzt etwas für sie zu essen bekommen
wie sollen wir jetzt überleben
die ganze Familie lebt vom täglichen
Lohn den mein Sohn nach Hause bringt
wenn er auf einer Baustelle Arbeit
finden kann dann bekommt er 400 Rupien
knapp 5 €. das ist alles was wir haben
unsere Welt bricht zusammen ich kann die
Regierung nur bitten meinen Sohn frei zu
lassen sonst schaffen wir es nicht ich
muss mich umbringen ohne meinen Sohn
Verzweiflung überall Recht wird
durchgesetzt aber gerecht scheint das
kaum zu sein
eine kinderehe ist damit nicht null und
nichtig sie gilt weiter auch nachdem die
Behörden jetzt durchgegriffen haben das
ändert nichts auf der anderen Seite wird
von Selbstmorden berichtet davon dass
Frauen verstoßen werden damit die Männer
nicht in Haft müssen
oder die gesamte Familie muss abhauen
ihr Dorf verlassen auf der Flucht vor
der Polizei
das alles bedeutet Chaos Unsicherheit
jede vierte Braut ist ein Kind
betrachtet man ganz Indien doch das
Phänomen ist ungleich verteilt je
ländlicher die Region je ärmer die
Menschen desto mehr Fälle gibt es
[Musik]
das Dorf tanzt
die Luft ist voll von Lebensfreude und
Übermut
eine von ihnen wird heute heiraten und
alle sind eingeladen das ist Ehrensache
das Hochzeitspaar Sana und Harrys sie
ist 16 R18 Jahre alt verraten uns die
Verwandten aber offiziell sagen sie 18
und 21 denn das ist das gesetzliche
Mindestalter für Braut und Bräutigam
Jünger zu heiraten ist verboten aber
verbreitet seit eh und je ich war auch
noch sehr jung als ich heiratete ich war
14 mein Mann 17 meine Familie hat das
entschieden und mich zu ihm geschickt es
war nicht mein Wunsch ein Vermittler hat
das arrangiert
fährt gegen Provision sorgt er dafür
dass Mädchen und Jungen zueinander
finden Liebe ist dabei keine Kategorie
es geht um nüchterne Interessen der
Familie
die Eltern treffen sich sitzen zusammen
sprechen und dann entscheiden Sie als
nächstes besuchen Sie das Haus der
anderen wie lebt der Junge wie lebt das
Mädchen verdient der Junge genug um für
das Mädchen zu sorgen wir sitzen
zusammen und reden über Geld
Braut und Bräutigam das ist ein Geschäft
danach kommt das Tanzen und Singen
[Musik]
Geldgeschenke dienen der Finanzierung
dieses Abends die Familie der Braut muss
zeigen dass sie es sich leisten kann
viele verschulden sich dafür
ein Sohn gilt als Segen eine Tochter als
Problem er verdient Geld sie kostet auf
dem Land bei den ärmeren ist dieses
Denken weit verbreitet und erst wenn die
Tochter verheiratet ist fällt diese
empfundene Last Weg
in ihrer eigenen Familie wie die Tochter
von Geburt an wie ein Gast betrachtet
der irgendwann gehen muss und in der
Familie des Ehemannes bleibt sie auch
eine ungebetene Besucherin eine
Außenseiterin das ist mehr Regel als
Ausnahme sie muss dann möglichst bald
schwanger werden und viel zu Hause
arbeiten
zwischen Regenzeit und Hitzewelle wird
geheiratet überall in Indien dann hat
das Glück Saison 10 Millionen Hochzeiten
jedes Jahr
der Bräutigam tanzt an mit seiner
Familie
[Musik]
fünf Tage dauern diese Feiern hunderte
Gäste sind geladen der Abend heute ist
der Höhepunkt er allein verschlingt
80.000 Euro
bezahlt von der Familie der Braut einer
Familie aus dem indischen Mittelstand
zu viel zu groß das gibt es nicht
Wohlstand muss gezeigt Bilder produziert
werden koste es was es wolle
wie im Märchen wie in Bollywood
aber anders als bei schroti und Anorak
ist die Hochzeit oftmals eben kein Traum
und die Ehe erst recht nicht denn sie
kommt viel zu früh so
seit 1968 gilt in Indien ein Gesetz das
Kinderehen für illegal erklärt
aber tatsächlich kommt weltweit jede
zweite Minderjährige Braut aus Indien
nirgendwo sonst gibt es mehr
Minderjährige Bräute als hier
dem Gesetz zum Trotz wir haben also
dieses Gesetz aber für die Umsetzung
wird so gut wie nichts getan die Zahl
von Kinderehen in Indien hat sich nur
minimal nach unten bewegt
wen das Gesetz nicht schützt der muss
sich selbst schützen jenty ist gerade 17
geworden was immer Sie sich vom Leben
erträumte drohte plötzlich zu platzen
Mama und Papa wollten dass ich heirate
deshalb bin ich von zu Hause weggelaufen
wenn Mama und Papa mich damit in Ruhe
lassen würden würde ich gerne wieder
nach Hause und bei ihnen leben jedes
Kind möchte doch bei seinen Eltern sein
aber ich muss jetzt erst einmal hier
bleiben
hier das ist ein Kinderheim ein
Zufluchtsort weisen sind darunter aber
eben auch viele die weggelaufen sind
hier haben sie eine Chance werden
unterrichtet lernen lesen und schreiben
und entkommen einem Schicksal dass Ihr
Kind sein früh beendet hätte
Ursache viele der Kinder sind gerade mal
14 15 Jahre alt dann wollen ihre Eltern
sie schon verheiraten die Nachbarn
fangen an zu reden sagen es wird Zeit
und die Vermittler kommen zu ihrem Haus
so beginnt das alles
wenn wir davon erfahren versuchen wir
die Mädchen da rauszuholen und manche
kommen auch auf eigene Faust
ist so eine eine die den Mut hatte ihren
eigenen Weg zu gehen sie möchte
Polizistin werden dann sagt sie könne
sie Menschen helfen die ungerecht
behandelt werden was das heißt weil sie
nur zu genau
sagte meinen Eltern dass ich weiter zur
Schule möchte im Leben etwas erreichen
will sie fragten mich wofür soll das gut
sein für sie hat Bildung keinen Wert sie
waren selbst nicht in der Schule und sie
haben darauf bestanden dass ich die
Schule verlasse und heiratete
ein Unrechtsbewusstsein ist bei den
Eltern kaum zu finden und auch die
Polizei geht nur allzu selten dagegen
vor
Kinderehen werden geschlossen als
stundentradition und sozialer Regeln
über dem Gesetz
es ist klar wir brauchen den
gesellschaftlichen Wandel die Menschen
müssen begreifen was für ein
paarchalischer Quatsch das alles ist weg
damit jetzt oder nie sonst wird sich
auch in den nächsten 20 Jahren nichts
ändern dafür braucht es Aufklärung
Bildung aber nicht Zwang Strafen und
Festnahmen das führt nur zu
Zerwürfnissen in der Gesellschaft zu
Angst
doch die gesellschaftlichen Strukturen
sind verkrustet dagegen anzugehen ist
schwierig ein weiterer Weg
das Team aus dem Kinderheim fährt heute
in ein kleines Dorf ein mobiles
medizincamp werde aufgebaut verkündet AJ
kostenlose Behandlung für jeden
jenty und die anderen packen an
und das Wartezimmer auf dem Dorfplatz
unter freiem Himmel fühlt sich schnell
mit Patienten alte junge Männer Frau
Mangelernährung schlechte Hygiene viele
Krankheiten sind darauf zurückzuführen
besonders trifft es Mütter die selbst
noch Kinder sind das Durchschnittsalter
bei der Geburt des ersten Babys liegt
bei knapp 17 vor allem unter solchen
Lebensbedingungen ist das gefährlich
die jungen Mütter kommen mit
Rückenschmerzen Knochenschmerzen
Calciummangel Blutarmut sie haben viele
Probleme nicht ohne Grund dürfen Mädchen
erst ab 18 heiraten ihre jungen Körper
sind einfach nicht bereit so früh Kinder
zu bekommen
und doch scheint ihr Leben vor bestimmt
das ist anders sein könnte kommt vielen
gar nicht in den Sinn dieses Denken
aufzubrechen ist schwierig jenty und die
anderen Kinder aus dem Heim versuchen es
spielerisch eine kleine Aufführung aus
dem wahren Leben jähnt die spielt die
Tochter die sich ihren Eltern
wiedersetzt die nicht heiraten will noch
nicht während sich Mädchen aber in
Wirklichkeit oft ihrem Schicksal ergeben
wehrt sich jenty in ihrer Rolle bekommt
sogar Hilfe von der Polizei einem Anwalt
erklärt den Publikum worum es geht ihr
macht euch strafbar sagt der zwingt eure
Töchter nicht zu heiraten
ich spiele hier mein eigenes Leben nach
so ist es mir auch ergangen deshalb
gefällt mir meine Rolle ich kann damit
Aufmerksamkeit schaffen kein Mädchen
soll gegen ihren Willen verheiratet
werden kein Mädchen sollte das erleben
müssen
[Musik]
sie singen ich bin ein Mädchen ich
möchte ein Stern am Himmel sein und bis
zum Mond fliegen
in Wahrheit sind Ihre Wünsche kleiner
ein selbstbestimmtes Leben das wäre
schon was